morning everyone
I'm delighted to be here thanks to the
organizers for inviting me and I'm
excited to be able to tell you a little
bit about some new work in our lab this
was just published this month in genome
research and it's the first time I'm
talking about it it's primarily the work
of a senior graduate student who
finished in November named John Liang
Zhang
so I probably don't need to tell this
audience but nucleosomes are abundant
and fundamental across eukaryotic
genomes they're the most fundamental
unit of packaging and they play a role
in regulating the accessibility of the
genome to factors that are involved in
replication and transcription as you all
know but just to remind you typically
around 147 base pairs of DNA are wrapped
around the histone octamer there is an
axis of symmetry called the dyad which
is the central position of the DNA and
if you rotate the nucleosome around that
axis then you essentially see the same
kind of position and everyone knows that
identifying nuclear zone positions is
particularly important to understanding
its role in these various regulatory
processes now historically there have
been two major uses of nucleases to
profile chromatin there are many others
but I'm going to focus here today on MAS
and DNA's and by way of contrast M&A is
an endo exonuclease that's small enough
to cut linker DNA between nucleosomes so
this has been the workhorse for
positioning nucleosomes across genomes
you digest the genome with mas you
isolate typically size selected
mononucleosis and sequenced them to
position nucleosomes this has been done
extensively in yeast but it's a little
bit too expensive to do it in human as
far as we know there's only one study
that's attempted this and the data is
still quite noisy and hard to interpret
on the other hand DNA's has primarily
been used to probe open chromatin and
it's been used extensively across the
human genome there are hundreds and
hundreds of DNA's experiments
interestingly there's only one DNA's
experiment in yeast before we did this
experiment at this particular paper
there's this separation of roles where
M&A is used to position nucleosomes in
DNA's is used to study the regions where
nucleosomes aren't and there's been a
recent explosion in probing into the
fine detail of these dnase
hypersensitive sites and considering
things like transcription factor
footprinting in my lab has done some
work in that area but i'm not going to
tell you about transcription factors
today today I'm going to tell you about
a story that happens sometimes in
science where you want to use data for
one thing and as you explore it a little
bit you discover something completely
different and you follow it to its
natural conclusion and something
interesting happens so just so you know
before we worked out the structure of
the nucleosome with x-ray
crystallography people used to use DNA's
to probe its structure and very
carefully study how it would Nick the
nucleosomes so there is some rich
literature for understanding how DNA's
interacts with nucleosomal DNA and I'll
come back to that in a minute so we
asked the following question could we
use DNA's to explore not just
nucleosomes depleted regions of the
genome but actually nucleosomes
associated regions of the genome now why
did we think this might possibly be
feasible first there was a recent paper
in 2012 by brogard at all reporting very
precise locations of nucleosomes and
they did this without using M&A s they
use a different method in which they
genetically modified histone h4 so that
it would cleave the genome in very
specific positions and after a little
bit of data processing they were able to
determine nuclear zone positions down to
single base pair resolution which even
with mas there's a little bit of a two
to three base uncertainty even if in the
best of cases so the precision was much
higher also collecting DNA seek data of
high depth and quality is fairly routine
in these days so we thought there was a
lot of that available and when we
combine these we thought maybe we could
see something about how DNA's interacted
with the nucleosomes because of these
traditional paper
in the 70s and 80s and then maybe we
could formulate a statistical model to
position nucleosomes based on that
signal and what I'm going to describe
today is our work in these in these
directions so here's the set up
experimentally in the kind of data that
we had available to us as I mentioned
there was this chemical cleavage method
that provided precise nucleosome
positions in particular they called
something called nucleosomes Center
positions and they had a score to say
how confident they were about in how
well positioned that nucleosomes Center
was and we used the top 2,000 of these
these were across the East genome there
were 67,000 nucleosomes reported about
80% of the East genome believed to be a
fairly complete map and we chose the top
2,000 to be our positive set our
training set to do some exploratory
analysis about how DNA is interacted
with those nucleosomes we ourselves yes
these are done on populations of cells
right correct so the cell population
each nuclear zone will sample different
locations at different parts of the
genome those may be sampled with sort of
increasing fuzziness so in some parts of
the genome a nuclear zone in different
cells may hop all over the place or in
the same cell over time you could think
of it either way and in other places the
nucleosome may be locked in a little bit
more rigorously because of sequence
reasons or because of barriers and
things like that so in their data they
were able to distinguish between a
position of a nucleus ohm and it's the
score is roughly speaking the amount of
consistency across the population so as
that score goes up you expect that
nucleosome to be more strongly
positioned and that's why we focused on
the top 2,000 instead of all nucleosomes
because some of them would be fuzzier
and shifting around so it's basically
the places in the genome where
you're most likely to find this position
covered by I guess the right way to
think about it probably is that as this
score goes up you would expect a higher
and higher fraction of the cells in the
population to agree on the exact
position of that include zone but as the
score fusses out a little bit you see
alternative positions and the data
you'll see in the data that there are
alternative positions and they tend to
be slightly shifted from one another
okay so we collected our own DNA seek
tatah in yeast this is in conjunction in
collaboration with the Crawford Lab
Gregg is one of the authors on the paper
as well and just for comparison to make
sure we you know that our results that
we saw in our data were consistent we
also used the one data set that was
available for yeast DNA sequence was
collected in the Sam lab J Hessel birth
was the first author so what did we see
when we looked at these 2000 nucleosomes
Center positions and summed up the DNA's
cuts across those positions we saw the
following now first just as a small
aside everything that I'm going to show
you is what we call transformed counts
this is a very simple transformation we
take the number of cuts mapped to a
particular site and we put it through
the inverse hyperbolic sine function
inverse hyperbolic sine if you're not
familiar with it I commend it to you
it's essentially a log transform that
behaves well at 0 & 1 okay so once we
transform these counts and this is
mostly to do variance equalization and
to get really tall highly cut regions
like the DHS is to be on a similar scale
with the less cut regions of the genome
we saw this profile and it has or we
observed three basic components there's
some fine details but first you can see
that the overall shape is quadratic now
you're more likely to cut away from the
dyad than in the center of the dyad and
we believe this is largely because of
DNA breathing and partial unwrapping of
the nucleosomes such that there are
times when the ends of the DNA
are actually accessible for dnase
digestion because they've unwrapped from
the nucleosome making them more
accessible in more places second you see
a strong oscillatory signal and this
also makes a lot of sense this is
consistent with this literature from the
70s and 80s dnase binds in the minor
groove and occupies 8 to 10 bases in
order to sit down and as the DNA double
helix wraps around the nucleosome the
minor groove becomes very exposed to the
outer solution and then very buried so
back and forth the minor groove goes and
so the DNA's can cut here but then it
can't cut here but then it can cut here
and one thing surprised us
of course you expect because of the dyad
and its axis of symmetry for the orange
curve read from right to left to agree
with the green curve read from left to
right in fact let me just show you that
if I flip the orange curve around you
see that they're in striking but not
surprising agreement but what was
surprising to us was that as you move
from the 5 prime to 3 prime direction on
either strand or as you come into the
dyad versus leave the dyad there's an
asymmetry of behavior we have a couple
of theories about this the one that we
think is most likely is just the fact
that as you come around the first time
you're sort of on the top of the
nucleosome and it's easier to bind and
as you come around the second time
there's steric occlusion from the first
wrap of the DNA and we think that that's
the explanation regardless it's a
striking empirical pattern and so we
asked whether or not we could use it to
position nucleosomes across the genome
however we were a little bit concerned
because nice work by Harman and Remo and
also seen in our lab we identified the
fact that DNA's does have a slight
sequence bias and we also know that DNA
as it wraps around nucleosomes has a
sequence pattern and it has a
periodicity of 10.3 bases
in terms of these A's 880 dinucleotides
and GC dinucleotides and so we were
concerned that possibly the signal we
were seeing was just DNA's bias map to
sequence patterns in the genome and
reflected nothing of nuclear zone
positions so we were able to reassure
ourselves by looking at this data from
the Stan lab so this is the hassle birth
data first we reconstructed the same
pattern that we saw in our data for
nucleosomes the same 2,000 positions in
these genome but importantly their data
also included dnase digestion of naked
DNA without nucleosomes and that's what
these two curves are the Watson and
Crick strand patterns at those same
locations when there's no nucleosome
involvement and you see that there's no
strong oscillatory signal and that you
see no quadratic shape so our next
question became is the profile
distinctive enough to tell just by
looking at DNA data whether there's a
nuclear zone there or not
and the first thing we did was consider
this from a classification point of view
so we wanted to see if we could identify
the 2,000 nuclear zone positions from
random locations in the genome and
distinguish them in a classification
manner so let me tell you a little bit
about the model in its notation first
I'm just going to designate the Cutts
centered around a particular position in
the genome on one strand by an X vector
and on the other strand via Y vector all
of our models are going to consider
these two strands separately but sharing
the same model in the opposite direction
as you'll see after the transformation I
described we observed that DNA's cuts
tend to be normally distributed and also
that the variance is proportional to the
mean so we introduced this constant of
proportionality and fit it as it happens
it's not that interesting it's pretty
close to one and it's pretty consistent
across the genome so it's not a major
thing then we wanted to discuss how the
mean of each of these series would
depend on or be related to the DNA's
data and we decided to parameterize that
in the file
anyway we explicitly modeled the
quadratic shape so you have a level
parametrized by a a quadratic term
parametrized by B centered on the zero
point and then Z reflects all the
remainder all the oscillatory terms that
are superimposed upon the quadratic
shape and you'll see that we modeled the
X series as being in the negative
direction from the Y series but X itself
and Y itself are not symmetric about 0
when you're outside a nucleosome we just
assumed there's some constant level of
dnase cutting in no particular pattern
so that's a constant that's a different
a ok so with these two models we can
then write down the likelihood of the
data for being within a nuclear zone and
the likelihood of the data for being
without a nuclear zone as to alternative
hypotheses this is nothing more than the
product of the data at each position and
then the data for each strand and the C
here in the normal model
similarly outside a nucleosome there's a
normal model each position and each
strand the difference here is just that
here we have the constant model and here
we have the oscillatory profile we'll
come back to that in this particular
case we're going to assume that they
don't but here's let let me make one
point which might clarify the question a
little bit we're asking whether or not a
position a single nucleotide represents
the center of a nucleosome
okay so in the classification problem
and I said we pick 2,000 random
locations you might think well the
genome is pretty covered in nucleosomes
and so the probability that you're going
to find a spot that's covered by a
nucleus and not covered by a nucleus I
was pretty low but it becomes clearer
when you think the probability that a
single nucleotide is the center of a
nucleosome is pretty low it's more like
1 in 200 so our negative set is not
perfect but it to a first approximation
it it's mostly non Centers of nucleus
I'll come back to that so for now we're
gonna just start a simple thing to see
if we can distinguish nucleosomes from
non nucleosomes and then later we'll use
this to map across the genome and we'll
come back to whether or not they can
overlap that's a great question ok now
it turned out that so you could compare
the ratio of those two things just to do
a simple hypothesis test that which is
more probable it turned out that because
the local cutting level of the DNA's
across the genome is we're regionally
variable and there's some uncertainty
about that we considered a Bayes factor
instead in which we integrate out this
this a parameter so we don't fix it at
its MLE estimate but consider a
distribution over possibilities and as
you'll see we got slightly better
results with that I'll come back to that
so this is our final score it's nothing
but a description of the likelihood of
the data with the nucleosome compared to
the likelihood without a nucleosome but
in each case integrating out the a
parameter and later on when we come to
the mapping question all we're going to
do is take this score and KITT and
compute it for every position in the
genome and we'll get a curve and then
we'll break that curve down into
positions of nucleosomes so first how
does the classification work reasonably
well and we did it with both our data
and Hassell birth data we felt pretty
good after seeing this ROC curve that we
were able to do a reasonably good job
both the data agree when the nucleosomes
are fairly easy to distinguish as as
they become a little bit harder to
identify our data seem to be slightly
better I don't think it matters too much
coming to the question of this Bayes
factor versus the likelihood ratio we
tried a couple of different things we
started with the straight likelihood
ratio and we saw a lower a you see just
over 0.7 these last four columns we
considered what happened when you added
the base factor approach and they're in
two groups first in these two cases we
just fit the model with a quadratic we
ignored the oscillation thinking maybe
that was just too noisy it turns out
that you get better results when you add
the oscillation and there's some
interesting data there that's important
and it helps you position and
distinguish a nucleosome from and not
nucleus no in addition we also
considered whether we should integrate
out just a or a and B because a and B
didn't perform markedly better than just
integrating out a and because it's
computationally more expensive to do it
we just drop that so our final choice
was this one we use a Bayes factor we
add the oscillation and we integrate out
a that is a good question I don't know
the number off the top of my head yeah
it's yeah some of it could be from that
this is not this is more this is
sometimes people put these up to say hey
our method is way better than their data
or or whatever that's not really the
point it's more to say that the the
conclusions about which model to use are
consistent across the data sets we
focused on our data we confirmed that
all the major things we saw we're from
we're also present in the Hessel birth
data but we're not necessarily saying
that one data sets better than another
end we had 83 million reads I can't
remember off the top of my head how many
they had so when you don't need to grade
out Phoebe how do you sit
we said it as an M le value in the
training set we did a K fold what we did
at K fold cross validation and so we set
it on the training set and then test it
on the tester at the same thing with KK
K is the is the ratio between the mean
and the variance we also just set that
with an M le value okay so was it twenty
three million so it's it's almost four
times more data so can we exploit this
classifier to identify nuclear zone
positions that became the next question
not just classify you know that's a
pretty simple setting but to actually
map so to set the stage let me show you
for example a section arbitrary section
of the yeast genome you see two genes
here you see a promoter region in
between and this is the DNA's data raw
before transform that you would
typically see as you can see there's a
burst of cutting here in the promoter of
ESL one and that's the open chromatin
region that people usually focus their
attention on but what you can also see
is that because of the depth there's a
few cuts all along the genome and it
doesn't seem like there's that much
there we applied our transformation so
that we could put the two more on the
same scale and you see that it's still
quite noisy but maybe you start to think
oh there's oh there's a little dip here
and a corresponding dip here and maybe
there's something there so it's not
really obvious from the data but the
model is able to consider all of these
positions and compute a score at every
position and that's what I'm showing
here in green this is our score computed
at every position and it was reassuring
to us that it tended to peak at the same
locations that were identified by
brogard and their method as the Centers
of nucleosomes and this comes back to
your question these these little centers
can sometimes be separated by ten bases
there's some uncertainty about where
this specific
zone really is and our score also has a
lit and base-pair wiggle that we've
smoothed out here so you can see more
clearly where the peaks are why can't
the cross I understand that there is a
nucleosome that you sort of dare yes
absolutely left and right so why why use
this notion that there is one position
with it we don't we don't we don't use
that notion we don't use that mission
we simply train on 2,000 positions that
seem to be across the cell population
enriched at a single location not always
at a single location maybe 80% of the
cells have that nucleosomes in that
position and that's simply to train our
model we don't we don't insist that
that's true later on I'll come back to
that you'll see you'll see there's an
important point here no I am come in
complete agreement with you in fact you
know what I'm not talking about today is
some work in our lab that this is
fitting into related to compete and
compete as a model that says factors are
all over the place and they're dancing
and they're picking different positions
and they're moving and it's a giant game
of musical chairs and every cell is
doing something different so that it's
entirely the paradigm that that I hold
great so again just a sanity check that
this curve means something we did the
obvious thing of seeing what it looked
like when you stacked it up at various
locations genome features like
transcription start sites or origins of
replication or transcription factors
that are known to sort of fit in between
nucleosomes and you see that the
composite pattern recapitulates things
that have been reported in the
literature many times including and this
is just for comparison this is what the
brogard centers stack up to so you can
see there's a pretty good agreement
between all of these things
but that's just a curve how do you sort
of come to a prediction of the most
likely positions of nucleosomes so here
we are at this point I'm going to come
up with a map which is at each position
in the genome I'm going to call the
center of a nucleus on which you could
think of as the most likely position of
nucleosomes in that general region but
one of the things that let me just show
you what happens so one of the things
that happens here is when we draw these
ovals the way the algorithm works is it
takes the highest peak across the entire
genome and it calls that a nucleosome
and puts one and once it puts one it
excludes that region from other
nucleosomes but one thing it does is it
only excludes 117 basis not 147 and the
reason for that is because one nuclear
zone even though you think the center is
here it could shift it could shift a few
bases left or right and as it shifts a
few bases left or right we don't want to
knock out another perfectly legitimate
nuclear zone nearby we also know that
they partially unwrap so they don't
always take up 147 pieces so oh jeez
okay so you can see sometimes the
predictions actually overlap so what
does this map look like in comparison to
the workhorse for yeah yes
so like the area around the promoter is
correct yeah yeah there's a there's a
bit of a wider NFR a little bit of a
bigger space between these two and a gap
here I mean that's that's a question of
semantics I mean you could say what they
are is open to open to sufficient
digestion by DNA's to be detected as
gaps between nucleosomes and they're
open enough to emanates for sure that's
why people use M&A is to cut them DNA's
is typically had a little more trouble
in there and that's why people get a lot
more cuts in the open chromatin but this
is a question of categorizing a spectrum
let me let's talk more afterwards
because I'm behind so if you compare the
reported you can think of as the Viterbi
parse or most likely positions of
nucleosomes from the brogard data with
these various results that were reported
in the last few years from the Pugh lab
from the Sigala Widom labs from the Eyre
lab you see that MAS does a pretty good
job of mapping the reference map and
actually Jiang and Pugh combined all
these data sets to produce a consensus
map that does much better than any of
them individually and then when we
compared our DNA's map to these maps we
saw that we were doing essentially as
well there are some small differences we
have lower false positive and false
negative but we're again we're not sure
how much is just from sequencing depth
but the point is you can do just as well
using DNA's as you can with emanates
that's
but this is all in yeast we were curious
how this would scale up to other genomes
and how much sequencing depth you would
really need to see these little signals
in the nucleosome associated parts of
the genome so we subsampled our data and
we saw how the classifier would change
its performance this is our data now we
have about seven reads per nucleotide or
you know per genome length and then this
is the performance dropping off and as a
rough rule of thumb we thought it was
reasonable to think you need about as
many reads as the size of your genome to
do reasonably well so that's the
ballpark that's hard to accomplish in
human it's trivial in yeast it's pretty
easy in worm and fly but it's pretty
hard in Mouse and genome and human but
people have collected so many DNA's
datasets that we pooled data so we took
there were 70 cell lines of the same
cell from 70 different cell type from 70
different individuals we pulled them
together we applied our model from yeast
so no fitting to human and this is the
curve that we get and if we map nuclear
zone positions these are the ones that
we get this is the one Emma's paper
that's been done in human and you can
see that you can also learn positions
and the agreement is not quite as good
it's about two thirds overlap one third
we have a nucleus own where they don't
1/3 they have a nucleus own where we
don't but in both cases our data is
limited it's only it's less than one
read per nucleotide their data is also
quite noisy so there's still room to go
in the human case coming back to the
yeast data there was one more thing we
observed when we looked at how far off
our map was from the reference map and
when we computed the center-to-center
distance between the reference map
called nucleosomes and are called
nucleosomes we saw a very interesting
thing with all of the MMA's maps either
individually or collectively you see
that if you position a nucleosomes long
you shift it by a little bit and then
you're less likely to shift it by a
little bit more so you get a unimodel
distribution that falls off smoothly
you position a nucleosome differently in
a DNA's map versus the reference map
you're almost always going to be off by
a multiple of ten and this makes sense
because there's this oscillatory signal
and if you don't get it right here then
the best match might be one shift over
and so what we concluded was even if
we're not getting best center right and
maybe there is no the center that there
are alternative locations and that those
are ten base pairs apart and so we can
assess for the whole genome whether or
not this point in the genome when it's
associated with the nucleosome is likely
to have its minor groove exposed or its
major groove exposed because if a
nucleosome is there it will be in these
sort of discrete positions more likely
than not and so I'll say this quickly
because I'm out of time but with that in
mind you can essentially map across the
entire genome this oscillatory pattern
and ask whether or not this nucleotide
is likely to be exposed as a minor
groove or exposed as a major groove if
it happens to be associated with a
nucleosome and we looked at
transcription factor binding sites and
that we're within nucleosomes and we
found that they were more consistently
aligned with this pattern than you would
expect by chance so the black curve is
the oscillation minor groove two major
groove of the motifs Center and the blue
are random curves of the same size set
and the same properties but random and
I'll just close with this which is to
say that we looked at a number of
transcription factors in yeast which
were in blue or human which are in red
and we empirically observed that the
center of their binding site tends to be
quite aligned with either the major
groove being exposed by the nucleosome
or the minor groove being exposed by the
nuclei more than you might expect it is
sort of barren in the middle and one
interesting point is that if a factor is
a minor groove binder it's not
necessarily the case that it's binding
sites are
groove exposed by the nucleosome
sometimes they agree and sometimes they
don't and at first that puzzled us and
then we thought well this may be part of
regulation right these binding sites may
fit into the genome in ways that
sometimes the nucleosomes obscure them
from binding and sometimes the
nucleosomes present them to be bound and
maybe this is all speculation now you
know no data to show this but maybe
there's a connection between what we
call pioneer factors which can bind in
nucleosomes associated DNA more easily
and a phenomenon related to this but we
haven't explored it too deeply let me
just say thank you to my co-authors to
the great environment at Duke for doing
this kind of work for funding through
the years that's made this all possible
and as I take questions all of our
software is available online and github
and and we have pre computed tracks of
this nucleosomes score across the yeast
and human genomes that you can download
and explore if you want and with that
I'll take questions
so the answer to the question is do our
data show long stretches of non
nucleosome 'el DNA the answer is that it
would be hard to tell at this point and
here's the reason why in yeast we have
sufficient depth to cover the whole
genome and make calls like we predict
67,000 nucleosomes and cover the genome
just like you would expect a good
nuclear zone map to do some of you may
be familiar for example with a newly
published nucleo attack paper that does
something similar try to predict
nucleosomes from a taxi kata it's a nice
paper it's a great method but they only
predict about 13,000 nucleosomes so
they're not covering the yeast genome
however in the the East genome is known
to be pretty well packed and maybe the
question isn't quite as relevant in the
yeast genome in the human genome where
it might be an interesting question our
data is of such low depth that there are
swaths of the genome with almost no
reads but we and we don't predict
nucleosomes there but it's it's probably
more a limitation of the data so to
really answer your question I think you
depending on the organism you're
interested in for that organism you'd
want probably four or five reads per
nucleotide and then you could ask that
question so we can't answer it yet I
think the way to think of it is that
this is not unlike the so DNA's flash
and nucleo attack those are methods that
can position nucleosomes also but they
do it near DHS as ours is genome-wide
but you need enough depth that that you
actually are seeing reads outside of the
DHS's yes if you sequence at a depth
that the only reads you see are in DHS
is you're not going to be able to
conclude anything in between them if you
sequence at sufficient depth that the
majority of your reads are in DHS is but
you also see a smattering of reads
everywhere else we're good
yes yes to try to find you justice
exactly yeah there's ways you could do
selection of either based on length or
isolation of various things even
something like the yeah the digestion
protocol could be tweaked
there could be captured technologies
like like exome sequencing that might be
able to guide the pool towards parts of
the genome yeah that's that's exactly
right we haven't done any of that tuning
doing the break and yeah